hi my name is Jerry Thomas I'm from
Milwaukee School of Engineering and
today my talk will be about strategic
leadership and using simple games
9:07 zero-sum games to elucidate that in
the decision process theory
my name is Jerry Thomas and I'm gonna
talk today about some ideas if I can
make this thing work of using game
theory and in particular a decision
process theory to investigate some ideas
that are pretty simple that we all take
for granted and one of them is about
decisions like who owns a decision when
we make a decision you know we usually
think we own it right so when I drive
from Chicago down to Champaign I have
some choices right I can take a couple
of highways I can go down you know the
tall road or not the tall road I can
take a plane I can take a train but my
decisions in fact are limited and
they're limited by choices that are
outside of my control they're
constraints somebody actually had to
build the roads build the airplanes
build the trains build the tracks and
those choices were made a long time ago
outside of my control so if I have a
theory of how we make decisions in that
theory I had to take into account those
constraints we do that all the time in
physical theories when I talk about
standing on on the podium for example
it's static but I don't think into
account the fact that it's actually not
really static it's made up of atoms and
the atoms are moving up and down and I'm
probably moving up and down a little bit
despite nerves right independent of that
I'm moving so how do we do that that
would be a an entire course I'm gonna
use the ideas that come out of game
theory and out of decision process
theory to talk about how we might deal
with those in a simple way so first so
my background is in physics and the way
I go about understanding things is I I
picked toy models and I'm gonna pick a
very simple toy model of a game called
rock scissors papers everybody know what
that game is right rocks
papers you know that game it's a simple
game but I'm gonna use it to try to
undercover or
lucid date the idea behind making
decisions so the first thing I'm going
to do with rock scissors papers is we
know that as a game where everybody
plays the game the same way right but
what if I change the nature of the game
a little bit I could do that I can make
rocks a little bit more exciting for
each player so I'm gonna do that and
that makes the game no longer a zero-sum
game but a nonzero-sum game so that's
kind of an interesting thing and part of
what I will do in talking about that
game is talk about something from game
theory which is called Nash equilibrium
which is this very if anybody know what
Nash equilibrium is yeah it's some idea
about a max min solution to linear
programming that comes out of game
theory that says people tend to do
what's best for them having considered
all the worst things that could happen
to them I think I said it right so
that's kind of standard for a for a
static game we're gonna find that that
is not an appropriate definition of
stationary behavior when you have
dynamics and I think people that study
dynamics would understand that see that
right away so game theory concepts since
somebody knows Nash equilibrium you
probably know as much as anybody here
about game theory but the the key idea
of game theory is for me there are
certain strategies that we can choose
and we can make we can turn a game of I
do this you do that I do this you do
that boil it down to a single strategy
of what was my choice what's his choice
we make the choice once that's the game
decision process theory and the other
hand says those set of choices are like
a space and in that space it's a point
in those points can move over time so as
opposed to static we can now have things
that move
so if we incorporate that the only thing
that we are missing then is how do we
incorporate constraints and we do that
in the theory that theory does that in a
very nice way just like it's done in
physics that you treat constraints as
stresses that are outside the theory but
you can specify if you like their energy
and momentum you make sure that you
treat some properties correctly which
allows you to do kind of like a least
action or least path for the whole game
let's see so for a zero-sum game or a
nonzero-sum game in a geometry one of
the key aspects of a geometry is it may
it may work in a space that's more than
one dimensions okay and in the space and
game theory typically you think of a
game as a game matrix and it has some
values but the game matrix will be
multiplied by a number like a charge and
if you take the analogy of a charge a
little bit further if you had a charge
between two plates it could produce a
field in the field that it would produce
might be the game matrix so if it's a
constant field that would be just like a
capacitor that's the idea and the
distinction between a zero sum and a non
zero sum game would be which way are the
fields going okay for your zero-sum game
they go in the same direction non zero
sum game they would go in the opposite
direction so that would be our our key
and this is moving a little bit faster
so
I'm gonna not do a lot of the the this
notebook by the way it was set up to be
used by students so it has an
initialization set which I'm not going
to do and the students can then just go
to a list of possible games or add their
own games and so they can go and they
can look up oh I want to do a
rock-scissors-paper game they can go
find a rock-scissors-paper game and they
would set up a game matrix ok so the 0
to minus 1 just I kind of compressed and
I did a new matrix form to make it into
a nice matrix but the two that you see
there would be a one in a normal game
that's the piece that I added that makes
it a non zero sum game and then if you
play rock scissors paper right what are
the choices you normally make a third a
third a third right you just play each
one equally right so if I change the
nature of the game by adding the two
well I don't play them equally anymore
but each player sees a different value
to what is unequal so if they both did
it I could try to make a composite game
out of that and this is what I would get
the composite game would behave actually
very differently from what I would have
expected what would I have expected the
first thing I expected when I did it for
the students is it would just oscillate
around some some value okay I would
believe yeah the values are gonna be a
little different it's what I didn't
expect is I get this exponential
behavior what's the exponential behavior
coming from underlying the theory there
is a game matrix which looks like an
electromagnetic field which has both the
time and a space component the space
components give you really payoffs which
are just like a magnetic field but
that's the game matrix
the time components give you an electric
field which is really the valuation the
game values of what happens when you
play the game the eigenvalues of such a
thing can be both real and imaginary I
just had the magnetic field it would be
purely oscillating around the magnetic
field the other parts are because I can
have things which are growing
exponentially that's okay
time grows exponentially to the relative
rates are still great there's nothing
wrong with that it's just I didn't
expect it is that the actual behavior
however that we would expect my argument
is no my argument is like a minute what
we looked at just now although the space
is fairly complicated I mean it's like a
9 dimensional space or something 3 & 3
are 6 which is time is 7 but each one
has their own internal strategy two more
that's 9 in a nine dimensional space how
do I track that well if you're familiar
with tracking phenomena for fluid flow
for example as opposed to tracking
everything you track a stream and then
for each direction in space you track
how the stream behaves that's the
velocity of the stream if there are two
players what's new is they each see a
different world they each have a
different boundary conditions so they
each have their own version of a stream
so the two directions I should choose
with the stream of player one stream of
player two now instead of getting
differential equations to solve for the
streams I get partial differential
equations because I their couple now
because I have two streams to consider
so I have to consider a mesh and
unfortunately I did this before version
12 so I had to iterate my my partial
differential equations are nonlinear so
I had the
rate them which was a pain in the neck
so I had to specify how many times I was
going to iterate them keep a little
progress bar the iterations took a long
time so I didn't that's why I'm not
doing it for you in real time but that's
the iteration so I'm not going to do
that but once I've iterated the solution
my behaviors along the diagonal when
that when the the two streams are equal
for the honor streams are equal is no
longer what we saw before it's it's
quite different and this is I claim not
just an artifact of this toy game but
it's it's a real fact when you start
thinking about it about any game must
work any game can have nash equilibrium
values on the boundaries where each
player thinks they own what's going on
but they own at this boundary this guy
owns it on that boundary what goes up
the middle they don't own but the
equations on it the equations can
understand how to interpolate from the
boundaries to the middle and this is the
behavior you get if you're looking a lot
more detail I might come back and talk
about what I what is market capital but
here is would be the flows of one flow
versus the other flow we just saw long
in the diagonal this is now a lot more
general looking at the two flows you
know if I solve the equations exactly I
would have a nine dimensional set of
partial differential equations I could
really track things but just like stream
lines are very useful these ownership
flows are very useful for getting an
idea they already show that potentially
those flows could turn in on themselves
and I've run solutions where they
actually do so you can get vortices out
of this you just have to turn up the
values of of what's going on
so you can look in more detail for each
of the strategies individually as
opposed to a single curve you can look
at each curve for example this would be
player so I have blue and red blue is
player 1 red is player 2 blue and red
comes from IBM when people from the Cold
War right red were the bad guys blue
were the US guys right so I picked the
same same model so this is red which is
player 2 choosing rock you can see it's
not like along the boundary you can see
it's pretty constant but you can see
what the equations do in terms of
boosting things up and it's a little
asymmetric and you would expect scissors
and paper they will have some behavior
which would be interesting to sit down
and think about but for time I won't go
through all of that and then blue it's a
symmetric on the other side and for rock
and you can go through and look at the
and of course time is a variable - so it
has it has a behavior now time in this
sense is is like the physical time and
as you go along a path then you have a
propagation time so you take all of that
into account so that's what you get and
what we did depend upon really focused
on the constraints so here's here's what
went in it I said the decisions are like
creating pass along the highway these
constraints are their constraints ok and
they're set by assessing stresses that
say here's what each player sees now
each player
ideally sees stresses if you thought
about it as a fluid the stresses would
be from each player's perspective sort
of isotropic they wouldn't the things
that they think they own they would say
yeah
all the same to me and the other play
would have the same thing now in the
world in which they play those stresses
might not look quite so isotropic so I
can actually look at what that take the
take the different strategies create an
ellipsoid of the stresses and see how
isotropic or not is it well that looks
pretty isotropic if you look at the
equations of the ellipse the the error
not an error but the the and I sucked me
be an eye surgeon I can't say that one
any other the non isotropic nature is
very small the flows each player has an
internal strategy which nobody cares
about which is the which was what I call
their their internal flow their internal
flow since nobody cares about it is
effectively a symmetry of the of the
theory and so it acts like a charge it
turns out in different initial
geometries that's always true whenever
there's a charge there will always be
always be an electric and a magnetic
field associated with it and if there
are two players there will be two such
fields if they're ten players there will
be ten such fields it sounds like really
weird if you're in particle theory it's
not really weird at all it just says
when you have unified theories you have
lots of these fields and in this case
the fields are very simple they're sort
of you one feels there and they all
commute with each other so each player
has a charge or flow that they see along
their boundary it has a behavior between
these two plates that goes from one to
the other and therefore it has a shape
and then the shape gets propagated from
the theory just as well as all the other
flows in this case those flows are very
simple
see so we did this for
rock-scissors-paper
there's another game we could do which
is how many people know how to play
tic-tac-toe right we all know how to
play tic-tac-toe but how many people
know what the strategy is to win or to
make sure you don't lose you all know
there is one right but can you
articulate it you don't remember it
right so but it's a game right and it's
an interesting game because first of all
to articulate what those strategies are
illustrates a very fundamental issue in
game theory which is how I distinguish
between playing the game of tic-tac-toe
and isolating or characterizing what
those strategies are where do I find the
answer for the tic-tac-toe I got a
Wolfram as a matter of fact it's all
there I just go to Wolfram Alpha and say
tell me all about tic-tac-toe and it
tells me there are nine strategies nine
pure strategies that I can make which is
specified by the nine boxes of
tic-tac-toe but what I do for each of
those boxes is not symmetric between the
two players X's player one always player
two so I won't go through the details
again but needless to say that there's
there's a decision tree matrix that's
associated with making each of these
boxes and of that decision tree it turns
out it doesn't really matter the X's
choice doesn't have to be all nine X
either chooses the middle box a corner
box or an edge it doesn't matter which
corner Anja picks it's all symmetric but
then I have to keep track of all the
nine choices for the other guy so if I
do that and I work out the game
matrix for that I get Nash equilibrium
and now the difference however is if I
just do the Nash equilibrium I'm gonna
get since they're zero-sum game nothing
exciting happens but in systems where
nothing exciting happens what do I do I
take a hammer and I hit it called a
disruptive force okay
so the standard way to understand this
system is hit it with a force and then
see what happens so I have a disruptive
flow there and I hit it and I see things
some of the choices oscillate I think
and some of the choices are like pretty
good Oh one by the way is if you're a
player oh your best strategies always
hit the middle and you can see that
that's like but the other strategies if
you if you do sometimes one of the other
strategies it generates little
oscillations for X and so on so the
dream is played over and over again
treat this now as ownership game now
again two dimensions again iterate it
this version my iterations was not as
successful because my mesh was really
not very good that's where I'm hoping
that the new Linde solve is really going
to help me out by the way when I did it
a quite different way these curves are
really nice and smooth and because I can
choose really nice meshes and has the
same characteristics here but I chose
I'm gonna do the same use the same model
and
focus on here again there's a neutral
behavior which is different from the
Nash equilibrium
the Nash equilibria in this case would
be just to choose one of this one of the
stationary pieces nothing no excitement
and I could have done that and I would
have gotten for this stationary but if I
choose a disruptive flow which is
dynamic I hit the system the neutral
behavior is different and you start to
see a lot more turbulent behavior
because why because I hit the system so
again I can look in detail at player you
know the best choice nothing exciting
lots of structure though on the sort of
the non-ideal choices one of my students
by the way use this type of model to
look at some game situations and solve
it really sort of the same thing the
people who play games on the internet
they know that there's certain optimal
choices and if they play it everybody
knows their optimal choices other people
then will disrupt the system and play
non optimal choices and it causes little
oscillations in the overall system and
they're stable there and they keep going
back and forth and these are stationary
oscillations not behaviors that will
somehow go away or transient it's a
distinction if you think of an analogy
between electromagnetic theory there's
DC currents and AC currents which are
both stationary both different from
looking at transient behaviors these are
not transients these are pure stationary
behaviors so lots of things that we can
do with that conclusions might take away
is that the strategic ownership is a key
thing in decision-making it's one that's
ignored because it's
it's invisible mostly because we
normally don't we just assumed that
there are choices we forget the fact
that there are roads that determine our
choices because of that well we should
focus on will not be things traditional
game theory things like Nash equilibrium
but we will have to consider what are
the neutral behaviors and it's the
amalgam of the processes of the
equations okay
some kind of geodesic or least shortest
distance between two paths and setting
up the boundary conditions so the
ownership reflects both those two
options another aspect which I didn't
have time to talk about is in addition
to he says stop I'm going to go one more
minute there are additional things in
the theory that you have to pay
attention to which also have boundary
conditions so with that I will take
questions
[Applause]